now in fotheringham your book capital
offenses he's reading on page 180
something I did chuckle when I read
every night on the evening news they are
told that a cold front is moving down
from Canada giving the impression that
everything north of Buffalo is a frigid
waste which accounts for the number of
sophisticated American sports writers
who in the Toronto Blue Jays were in the
nineteen eighty five american league
playoffs phone canada radio stations
asking what time the sun went down
whether they would be able to exchange
our money and whether you could see
quebec from toronto what how do
americans look at canada uh well i think
as i said in my book they looked at
canada as a large refrigerator with the
door open because every night on the
evening news as a cold front is moving
down from Canada and and Americans seem
to think that as soon as you get through
a border somehow it turns into arctic
tundra and there's nothing but snow and
ice up there and we'll it's a big joking
in Canada but the American tourists are
used to arrive in toronto in august with
snowshoes and skis strapped on top of
their their cars but here we get hot up
there this time here oh yeah it's just
the same as it is here another thing
that was a in your introduction to the
current canadian regime of the jaw that
walks like a man what is that about
that's Brian Mulrooney our dear Prime
Minister and he has a rather dominant
jaw the cartoons have great fun with
them so this is what i call him the john
that walks like a man what do you think
of him well i invented him brian so i
have rather tell me how you invited him
well in 1975 the leader of the den
leader of the Progressive Conservative
Party was a guy called Robert Stanfield
and just lost the third straight
election to Pierre Trudeau and he
announced that he wanted to step down
and with the party please call the
leadership convention so and my column
in McLain's I ran down the list of all
prominent conservatives who were going
to run and i said this guy's tube
dumbness guys two youngest guys too
stubborn and central sector and i said
that if
the tories had any brains which they
haven't demonstrated as yet they would
nominate a young guy and I'd never met
him at that time but I've been following
his track record Brian Mulrooney and I
explained that the only way the Tories
were ever going to get elected was to
break into Quebec Liberals have always
dominated Quebec team is why they've
dominated Canadian politics the last 80
years and I said that this kid Mulroney
he was young he was bright he was a
lawyer at a beautiful wife he was
fluently bilingual and why not give him
a try so but a week later my secretary
buzzed me and said Alan there's a mr.
Mulrooney from montreal on the phone and
i picked up the phone and i didn't even
say hello i said when did you decide to
run and he said the second time i read
it in your column so i invented them and
they elected how's he doing ah he's
starting to come back a bit now but he's
had a very rough three years he's never
been in politics before he could evolve
it in at the at the top you never run
for anything before running for a leader
of his party and his inexperience shows
and he doesn't know enough about the
nitty-gritty of politics he tries to
rely too much in his Irish charm and it
hasn't worked and the Canadian public
doesn't quite trust him they think he's
a little too slick a little too charming
and he's got a tremendous majority of
course in I was 211 seats but he's way
down in the polls his party's running
third in the polls at the moment but he
doesn't have to call an election for two
years so he may come back you're from
her SATs cat Chauhan that's right people
from her and her cold hernias where is
it Hearn is in the navel of the nation
Saskatchewan is that is right in the
center of the country just above North
Dakota and Hearn is a tiny little town
and south of Regina about 50 miles from
the American border why are you living
in the United States and what do you
think of us I'm living in the United
States because as I said I invented the
Prime Minister and I decided to come
down and save another country and I'd
never worked worked in in London and
ottawa on vancouver and i thought it
would be great fun to come down to see
who succeeds Ronnie ramble and you've
got this interesting race with the Seven
Dwarves on one side and five or six guys
I mean this is almost unprecedented that
literally 15 any 10 15 men could be the
next president of the United States
legatus well I think that you're the
most generous nation on earth of course
I think you probably are the most
insular nation I don't think Americans
really like the mantle of world power
and I think this whole protectionist
moved at Japan bashing Lee Iacocca and
the rest are doing so well and I think
that indicates a mood that America is
rather sick of its responsibilities of
world leadership and I think there's a
feeling in the country if I get a sort
of pull down the covers and you pull
down the blinds and get on with what you
do best and let the foreigners the hell
with them why do we feel that way well I
think because of the the disappointments
of Vietnam for example the tragedy in
Lebanon having to pull out of there the
sort of impending sense that there may
be another Vietnam going in Central
America and i think americans say why
should we get involved again overseas in
struggles that we don't understand this
oo iran-contra mass people are shaking
their heads they cannot believe that
this president they trusted so much
could get embroiled in another mass
which in a way is worse than watergate
the implications are worse than
watergate could something like
iran-contra happened not not the event
that the hearing is the process of going
through now happened in Canada it
possibly could on a smaller scale but we
don't have the clout or the interest to
get involved on on a world scale but
I'll tell you one thing a thing like
Watergate could have happened
can we never would have heard about why
because our system our parliamentary
system a prime minister who is elected
with the majority in effect is an
elected dictator he can do anything he
wants he has extra Mendes party
discipline we don't have yours is a far
more democratic system and a far more
open system or the checks and balances
with Congress vying with the President
and you know in our country the Prime
Minister controls the Parliament so
severely that they could squelch it
you'd never hear anything but Alan
fotheringham has a book out and we held
up earlier let sue seiki keep order
books is that a Canadian publisher can
you buy the United States yeah called
capital offenses and there's a lot of
humor in this how does she what's the
difference between a Canadian humor an
American here I don't know I think like
most things Canadians halfway between
British and American little more subtle
I think than American humor mr.
fotheringham as we said is from her
incites Quechuan he's a columnist for
south of news chain of newspapers in
Canada has roughly three million
readership in that column and also we
could call them in claims national
magazine similar to time the same as
Canada's news magazine been here in this
town of washington since 1984 call from
right close to the Canadian border
superior Wisconsin go ahead please yes
oh it was good morning see spoke yeah
come on turn your television sent down
president I didn't realize that I
thought a girl was going to answer for
that fear of journalists there you know
sir a lot of times we get foreign
journalists that come into the country
and make statements like wearing the
American people are fed up with contra
gate and we're embroiled in something
that's worse than watergate so and so
forth that's that that might be the
presses point of view of the national
news media has that point of view and
most of us are sick and tired hearing
about Iran gate most of us a lot of us
not most of us because we
get the truth as usual from our own
national news media we get a very
distorted left-wing point of view let me
explain something to not too long ago
when Admiral Poindexter gave testimony
he testified that Ronald Reagan was not
aware of any money being diverted to the
countries that is the only law which
they don't which there is a big question
whether even that would be
constitutional in that which is the
Boland Amendment so right up to this
point nobody is that disappointed in
mile Reagan because he's embroiled in
this message them as being dug up by the
news media so far there is not one side
tiller of evidence linking Ronald Reagan
to any wrongdoing okay your reaction
that John was called from New York I've
nice wrong button well I think we'll
wait for the panel the congressional
panel which is sitting that's what
they're there for North is coming up
next week our caller said that
Poindexter testified Poindexter is no
testified yet he's coming up on fifteen
that's what the whole Schmeer is about
that the panel wants Poindexter to
testify in public as to what the
president knew and what he didn't know
superior Wisconsin I'm sorry I keep you
waiting I would just like to ask this
gentleman slide that when our ships are
into Canada FISA they're treated so
shabbily and the Russians are treated so
royally any examples you can give us yes
I well I know this to be true so I was
just wondering why and and I would like
to make make a statement first before he
answers the question okay let me ask you
this what evidence do you have what's a
penis specifically the Canadians do with
our ships and not with the solar they're
not treated nicely at all in there and
but the Russians are treated very well
but I would just like to make a
statement before he answers the question
and I agreed with the last caller we
have very few Patriots that in
Washington and what
President Reagan is the true patriot and
Ollie north are fighting communism but
it's like the rest of them all around
they've got every one they have gotten
rid of everyone that has been true to
Reagan they've got everyone out and now
they're after mr. me okay thank you what
about her original state well I don't
don't understand what she's talking
about really I don't know if Russian
ships ever come to Canada I suppose some
do aside from freighters not only thing
i know i'm from vancouver and whenever
an American destroyer battleship comes
in they have to put up the barriers for
the nine thousand young girls who gloat
to the parties they all advertised
entertainer a Yank and I usually go away
with about six engage girls and several
marriages some months later and I I
don't think the American sailors think
they're treated badly in Canada Alan
fotheringham is based here in Washington
he writes a column weekly for Canadians
and has a book out called capital
offenses dr. Bob so what they call you
meet some cool Sam arlington virginia
you're next yes good morning I have a
couple questions for your guests one I
was wondering why it's a bet in Canada
or Canadian politics you've got quite a
distinction between the federal level
and the provincial level it take a
province like Saskatchewan which for
years is had a CCF or New Democrat
provincial legislature and yet elects a
complete unanimous late of PCs to the
federal parliament it's the strange to
be why is it that people vote completely
differently from provincial level to the
federal level because they want to keep
the politicians honest to keep them off
guard this is a traditional thing the
Saskatchewan has a Conservative
government at the moment and they would
send several new democratic members more
than several to Ottawa the provinces
like to have a balanced and they will
vote a one-way federally but the
provincial government they will vote
way and it's essentially to keep the
politicians off guard the voters aren't
completely dumb second question when I
had is I understand there is some more
recent amendments the Canadian
Constitution I understand they've been
talking about having direct elections
for the Canadian Senate what is the
prospects of this happening in would
Canadian senators be elected for a term
of six or eight years or what's the
current proposals thank you and would
you please explain how the Sun is now
selected the Senate being the upper
house is appointed unlike your Senate
House of Commons is collected of course
the Senate is appointed by the party in
power and it does it have any power it
has a sober second thought mr. term that
they can on money bills and important
bills they can install in delay they
would if they ever really tried to defy
the governing party there would be
trouble but what they can do is delay
and force public opinion into coalescing
around a certain point of view are they
thinking of direct election yes they are
thinking of letting the provinces first
of all appoint the Senators rather than
being important from ottawa fremont
california go ahead please yes please
how many families have on na interview
now bouquets could be passed both ways
several years back at 658 I had the
chance to do some fishing up in Canada
across from Quebec and I was never more
pleased with the courtesy respect and
cooperation than any country have ever
been in so I think Canada is not only
wonderful place to visit but possibly a
very good place to live okay thank you
where's your favorite spot in canada
vancouver of course second most
beautiful city in the world what's the
first Hong Kong Corning New York your
next morning morning
I'd like to tell us no manera we go to
st. Catherine's allowed him in throttle
beautiful beautiful and I remember the
saying I heard up there years ago it's
that you have friggin and Bob Hope and
we have to do and no hope but I think
that's changing around the Reagan spear
carriers they heard on here this morning
you know they're saying that nobody's
interested what's going on to watch and
I don't think that's further from the
truth they don't want to hear anymore
they're grasping on any straw to get
ahold of 2a and I think Reagan's are
pretty a good man as far as a certain
thing but he does a lot of crazy things
too like this Persian Gulf I was just
wondering what the can of Canadians
think about this Persian Gulf where the
guy says we are defending the Persian
Gulf took the ship security oil against
the policy we don't have and the people
that won't help us out the countries and
all this stuff and oil we don't use what
do they think about that up there I
think the Canadian public is as confused
about what's going on Persian Gulf as
the American public is and putting
American flags and renaming Kuwaiti
liners naming them after New Jersey
City's doesn't quite seem to solve the
problem I think the public in Canada is
confused as the White House is on the
whole thing like Geneva Wisconsin go
ahead please yes I like this you're just
a question them I love cannon and I
think may incur is one of the great
cities along with Toronto but my
question is the United States State
Department does not allow some Canadians
authors people of summary now in Canada
into this country what is your view of
that and what's been your experience if
any with it well my view really couldn't
be expressed in on his family show like
this brain it's a crazy thing I hangover
from the McCarran act from the McCarthy
days and which certain people have been
barred from this country we have a
famous author called far
lameo becomes book of books have been
translated in about 30 different
countries and last year he was asked to
come down to California publicize his
recent book he was stopped at the border
I was not allowed to enter and the
excuse was that he had once threatened
to shoot down an american airline
airliner and Farley is a funny guy who
drinks a lot of romlin has a crazy sense
of humor roams around in a in a kilt and
when American Air Force bombers were
over flying Canada how many feet feet
you know miles up he went out in his
backyard with an old blunderbuss that
would shoot about 30 yards and he said
to a neighbor that he was going to shoot
down a plane for this he was banned from
the United States still it is banned
from the United States other people
prominent author who is an anarchist the
ban from the United States there's
talked to Washington Post writes
editorials about this how ridiculous it
is to have this McCarran act hanging
around in 1987 and then anybody from
this country not not that I know Rocky
Point New York gladly oh hi my question
is about the recent parliamentary
decision in Canada to oppose capital
punishment and to defeat that Pro
responsive bill and do you think that
this position because maroone did did
oppose the bill will increase his
popularity in the polls yes I think it
will because parliament voted on Monday
early Tuesday morning by 21 votes to
turn down a return to capital punishment
the United States is about the only
civilized advanced country that still
has capital punishment along with other
such people as as South Africa Russia
and the Arab states and I don't think
any civilized person wants to go back to
that goofy policy there's a large debate
in Parliament for about two weeks
and ma Rooney himself gave a very
eloquent speech was described as one of
the best speeches he's ever made in in
Parliament and while he allowed a free
vote in the Commons that his members
could vote any way they wanted he spoke
very strongly against capital punishment
and I think you're right color there
will help is popularity so Alan
fotheringham will be with us for another
25 minutes and we're talking about
Canada on this July first 1987 canada
day one of the quotes he's got in his
book doesn't doesn't attributed to any
unless it's anonymous is that Canada is
a decaffeinated United States will check
him on that moment see what he means
Boulder City Nevada go ahead please yes
good morning Brian good morning it would
be very helpful if someone like you
would generate some I'm speaking to your
guests I ideas on Western Hemisphere
economic Union I was particularly i
noted the previous guests there talked
about person from Costa Rica who
commuted to the US via Canada and as you
as we're all aware a lot of that extort
of thing occurs of course but Western
Hemisphere economic Union without any of
the taint of sovereignty becoming
involved is real real important for the
future okay thanks yes but you can't
have it without sovereignty being
involved it's impossible to will have an
economic union between Canada and the
United States without Canadian
sovereignty and perfectly what we call
cultural sovereignty endangered there
isn't another country in the world that
is so dominated as Canada is by foreign
magazines television movies publications
everything when you live a little
country the size of canada 26 million
people's population of california beside
a world leader 10 times sighs we refer
to it as the mouse sleeping with an
elephant
every little twitch makes you worry and
Canadians are very worried about trying
to retain some sense of Canadian
sovereignty in their book publishing
world in the making movies magazines
it's extremely hard to live beside a
country the size not be dominated by it
how long ago to stay here in Washington
till the end of Ronnie Rambo's term next
year when they select the new president
end of 88 Burlington Vermont your next
haven't been married to a radium citizen
for eight years actually do listen I was
wondering if you get a comment on youth
by politicians of the United States and
in some ways the British colonial
heritage as a foil to help define
Canadian identity I tables the context
of the loose confederation system the
Cannon has with the provinces being so
autonomous and all the respect that I
have noticed a piece of property
division between the French and English
population which is sometimes on the
right to the point of racism now to the
problem we've had black and white in
this country okay Burlington thank you
not sure what the question is Brian the
foil have Canadian Jews there you know
connection with the British to
connection the American to the floor I
apologize I wasn't asking the same
question to you sure certain canadian
called politicians use anti-americanism
as a foil as a weapon the same as a lot
of american politician are using japan
at the moment as a weapon and lee
iacocca running around the country Japan
bashing what's our name geppert Richard
geppert the Democratic presidential
candidate sort of leptin to prominence
with his amendment very strongly
prejudiced against the Japanese in that
mood as I mentioned earlier Brian
there's a protectionist meant mood and
isolation is mood moving in this country
and get bird for one is trying to
capitalize on it from your perspective
is columnist quickly named the
Republican the Democrat that you
yourself are most interested in right
now I think Bill Bradley is going to be
bob dole for the presidency Jennings
Missouri go ahead please good morning
I'd like to ask the again was just how
our regulations in Canada and that many
black Americans think that the South
means anything south of the Canadian
border as many blacks fled to Canada
escaped slavery Thank You Gil question
again I he's saying what a race
relations like in Canada where many
black Americans feel that anything south
of the Canadian border is full of racism
I only said exactly that and that's what
a lot of blacks fled to Canada and of
course there isn't the proportion was it
book twelve percent of the United States
is black Canada if it be one percent i
would be surprised it's increasing a lot
of immigration from pacific particular
with hong kong shutting down here in a
few years from british rule and to rule
from Peking people are fleeing Hong Kong
there's immigration of fair bit from the
West Indies but the proportion is such
it's so small that there's no real
problem Alan fotheringham our guest for
the next 20 minutes we're talking about
Canada we go to buffalo new york near
the border go ahead please yeah good
morning Brian morning I get over to
Canada quite often what I didn't
understand his remarks I thing it's hard
being our northern neighbor I believe we
have a cool 71 be in dollar trade
deficit isn't it our deficit that is
paying for all your national health
programs and when you turn Ronnie Rambo
you know the true that only about one or
two percent of your money goes to be fat
that most of everybody is take for your
defense is not only all your social
programs at the same time stay on the
line Buffalo if you would Canadians
would dispute your contention on the
trade deficit the dollar deficit the two
countries are
world's greatest trading partners of
course canada and america united states
sells more to counted as to any other
country in the world we have a stronger
feeling on social welfare the United
States does Canadians cannot understand
how this the richest country in the
history said what is laughingly call
civilization does not have a Medicare
system is marc brought in in medicare in
germany in 1897 and canadians are just
dumbfounded at the enormous costs that
people directly poor people ring up in
hospital costs here and we cannot see
how a country this rich cannot have a
proper Medicare system we feel more
strongly about a social welfare system
and we don't feel as strongly about
defense we know that we can't couldn't
possibly defender ourselves and Canada
does use the defense Sunbrella the
United States is no doubt about that
follow yes I mean but you wouldn't have
such a social conscience with all your
national build if it wasn't for us
paying your bills if the trade deficit
was when you had the Septimus billion
dollar trade deficit to the UM would you
still be able to support all these
programs in this our country there seems
to follow that your program with all
these new pub well programs they want
national health you want child day care
they want Perry on the leaf it's our
trade deficit instead of pain for your
program thank you I don't think that's
correct no one don't agree with that
Long Island you're next hello um I'd
like to find out about the nuclear power
in counted out there what if there is
any if you support Star Wars thank you
is a nuclear power the nuclear power
stations yes previous speaker mr. Doran
talked about the plan to buy 10 nuclear
subs to sort of patrol the Arctic
yeah the Government of Canada has been
going to say lukewarm about Star Wars I
would I think their position is that
they are they don't want to participate
that's what they've said they don't want
to participate in research on it or
contribute money to it we're where are
your favorite spots around the United
States San Diego love San Diego Love New
York for three days that's all you can
take before you collapse I like
Washington very much caution is a
beautiful city one month of winter idaho
falls idaho you're next I this thing to
find a whole quarter in Canada and I
would like to know why yeah night is a
kenda equal a motel the state's cost us
about 20 bucks you cook makanda gosh
about 30 if you go into Canada bring
some back to space a kidney and really
has it attacked on your health hi okay i
assume he's talked about the difference
to the canadian american dollars but are
motels and cost of living higher in
canada than they are in the united
states well they certainly aren't for an
American because in American dollars
worth the dollar thirty the cheapest
holiday you can get so here in American
canids a very inexpensive place to
holiday okay I think we've got a long
island are you back again yes I'm sorry
I cut off for another question about
Niagara Falls and all the energy that
can create by turning the turbine you
know with the water flowing and stuff um
I was wondering uh how much power cannot
generate I mean can it generate more
than this being allowed to and when that
helped in closed reduction of energy
expenditures and you know saving oil
prices thank you well I'm no engineer
Brian I don't know anything about
waterpower the only thing I know about
Niagara Falls
what Oscar Wilde said about it second
biggest disappointment and a bride's
life it's the biggest difference between
the American press in the canadian press
American press American reporters work
harder they are more educated than
Canadian reporters and they drink less
lake tahoe california next yeah looking
back at the 1984 general election in
canada it looked like the Progressive
Conservatives when a huge landslide but
looking at recent provincial elections
the Liberals are doing extremely well
and the New Democrats are doing
extremely well in the polls I was
wondering what you think the result of
the ontario provincial election will be
later this year and the canadian general
election will be probably next year what
you feel the results will be and how you
feel that might affect the united states
trade relations Connor why do you know
so much about the Canadian elections
because I was a poli-sci student in
college and Canadian and British
politics were one of my specialties okay
thanks your first question I can tell
you with certainty the ontario
provincial election will be a landslide
for the Liberals Premier David Peterson
is very popular no doubt about that the
next federal election if I could predict
that I wouldn't be an ill pay journalist
i'd be down at the racetrack making
millions of bucks prophecies the NDP is
in fact is leading in the polls at the
moment but I suspect that's illusory I
think Canadians are just parking their
votes with New Democrats at the moment
because they're confused they really
don't like Mulrooney they're very much
and the Liberals are all at sea at the
moment they're very confused and there's
talk that they will force John Turner
the leader out because the party is
split I still think it's possible that
Mulrooney and the conservative could win
the next so he can lose a hundred seats
and still be in power he has 211 seats
it'd be a minority government but I
think whoever wins it'll be a minority
government next time here on the
Pennsylvania go ahead please yeah like
now talk about
Canadian Army I really was not a
military base up there enough I thought
the equipment was quite chatty and I
didn't think they were 50s or 60s clip
why were you on a Canadian military base
as I we were up there at a friend canada
who's joining reserves up there gasps
and rip it took me to show me around out
there ontario what specific thing can
you point to that was shabby somebody
come out slings older than I'm in the
Marines reserve and I just never know it
just seems a bit older type equipment
than say we had these callers entirely
right Ryan during the years when Pierre
Trudeau was the prime minister he cut
back on defense expenditures and the
equipment both in the Navy Air Force and
Army is very rundown and shabby stew the
proper word the replacements weren't
provided and the Conservative government
now is trying to turn that around
they've increased defense spending our
guest is Alan fotheringham he has a book
out called capital offenses 1986
copyright although this has been a
serious program this morning there's a
lot of humor in this book Emily the
serious program because your mood this
morning or whether our callers are
clearly in the morning albuquerque new
mexico your next go ahead please good
morning Brian mr. fotheringham is that I
cannot that right yeah I'm sorry I would
like to know where the money's from the
canadian lottery go i subscribe to a
magazine of every month of that whole
back section of backpage is devoted to
selling the canadian lottery tickets
apparently goes all over the world can
you tell me we're all that money goes
any of it for helps the health care
actually I don't every pro every
province now practically has their own
lottery program and I think the
government takes a slice of it but I
really don't know it was an awful lot of
people play it a lot of money goes in
and I'm sure all of it doesn't world in
prizes do you play it no I would love to
but I can ever keep track of it
Southington Connecticut next go ahead
all right
correctly payment when why did you call
him Lefty that's the impression right
yeah you know Ronnie Rambo referee fre
Oh lefty that way what is that if you're
called a lefty in Canada saying I
thought he's talking about as South
Bobby that's just talking about the next
wing anyway know better I'd like to say
in my travels in Canada I really enjoyed
the calculator always will oversee
forget back to Reagan at the beginning
of his administration before he got into
office mostly oppressed for trying about
the economic policies are going to
direct the rationale for the country
usual HR not be wrong I wonder how many
people remember like I remember back
before he came to drop off we were
paying twenty one percent HSN love so it
seems rather through economic policies
turned out to be correct and now they're
looking for another skeleton in the
closet or whatever okay thanks Ryan I'd
like to refer to a point of one of the
early callers made and said that all of
Ronnie Rambo's problems being caused by
the left-wing press and marketed as a
matter of fact the leaders of the press
in Washington are right wingers George F
will is the hot columnist at the moment
very right-wing makes a million bucks a
year Evans and Novak right wingers the
dominant people in the in the press the
opinion makers are right wingers at the
moment are there any right-wingers and
Canada writing for a living oh yeah q
you as prominent as George will or Evans
and Novak non was making a million bucks
a year now Seattle Washington go ahead
please uh yeah good morning I noticed
that there's a new
ooh war Measures Act or replacement for
the war Measures Act being considered by
Parliament can you talk about the old
war Measures Act and how will the new
war Measures Act differ well I'm not
quite sure I saw a reference in the
press that the old war Measures Act was
something left over from the Second
World War when talking with all
governments and every emergency powers
most Canadians had never heard of it
until the separatists terrorists in in
Quebec started putting bombs in
mailboxes and as a kidnapping a Quebec
cabinet minister he was kidnapped and
murdered and Trudeau brought out the war
Measures Act and he arrested a slew of
people 117 people under the war Measures
Act threw them in jail not a single one
was ever charged or convicted and there
was great resentment over that old dusty
measure being hauled out of the law
books so the government is rewriting it
to make it as I take it useful and
applicable only in wartime and
insurrection and to take away these
sweeping powers where they throw people
in jail and and then never charged them
Detroit Michigan your next your last
also okay um my question is members of
the shin pain you with me yeah hello
yeah go ahead okay members of the
champagne political a party in Northern
Ireland haven't been allowed United
States for some time even though they
committed no crime d and they but they
were allowed in Canada we used to go
over to Canada to hear champagne
speakers now it just started two months
ago they weren't allowed in Canada with
that moorings decision and what do you
think of it they are now banned from
Canada you say that's the first time
I've ever heard of the shin sane some
people call them the IRA they're the
people who kill people in Northern
Ireland it's almost as bad as
and I I don't think either Canada or the
United States should allow known
terrorists in their territory why did
you use that quote inner book Canada is
a decaffeinated United States Americans
think of Canada as a dull place
Canadians call this country the excited
States of America so it's nick names we
have for each other the ambassador to
the united states mechanic refers to
Washington as the new Rome yeah why
because it's the center of the world
center of power it's as important now as
Rome was in those days of the Roman
Empire this is the most powerful city in
the world was a big sign the airport the
first thing you see if the National
Airport says welcome to the most
important city in the world and it is
the most important city in the world
every decision that made here affects
people all over the globe does that
offend you when you see a sign like that
now it sort of amuses me but it's true
Alan fotheringham is the author of this
book capital offenses dr. foth meets
Uncle Sam and his book as we said
earlier without 1986 can be bought here
in the United States mr. fotheringham is
a columnist for south of news which is
in Canada and can be seen in red by some
3 million people across the country has
also we could call him in Maclean's
magazine which is a national magazine
comparable to our national weeklies has
been in Washington to fall 84 and says
he'll be with us here in this country
until the end of Ronald Reagan's
presidential term thank you for joining
us thank you Brian and thank you for
being with us on Canada Day July first
1987 how good